what happens when the locks come face to
face with their new foe and will tyler
return home to help his family here's
what you need to know before you watch
the final season of lock and key
season three of lock and key has been in
production for quite some time and it
had actually been written before season
two even premiered producer carlton
hughes explained to collider
it was actually a really weird thing
that i've never experienced in my career
to have written a full season of
television that hadn't been made and we
had to go on to writing the next season
of television season 3 was also shot
back to back with season 2 meaning that
filming wrapped in september 2021 a
month before season 2 hit netflix connor
jessup who plays tyler locke on the show
posted a series of behind the scenes
snaps on instagram and wrote that's a
wrap on season 3 of lock and key after a
year of shooting we're done i'm a
tangled mess i'm sleepy and happy and
sad but mostly i'm grateful it's been a
weird year and this show has been a
refuge thankfully fans won't have to
wait too long for netflix to drop season
3.
netflix has been teasing locking key
season 3 on social media since the end
of 2021 but has been cagey with release
details until now during netflix's
geeked week event the streamer shared a
trailer for season 3 and revealed that
the series will return on august 10 2022
locking key season 3 will air a mere 10
months after season 2 compared to the 20
month wait fans endured between the
first and second seasons this highly
anticipated season will reportedly
consist of 8 episodes which is a
departure from the previous 10 episode
format hopefully this shorter season is
still able to mirror the success of the
previous season which was streamed for
more than 143 million hours globally
during its first four weeks on netflix
now that netflix has announced a release
date for season 3 fans are clamoring to
know if their favorite characters will
return for the next installment of lock
and key thankfully most of the show's
main actors have confirmed they'll be
returning connor jessup was one of the
first actors to reaffirm his place in
the series even though his character
tyler locke leaves to go traveling at
the end of season 2. jessup told decider
in october 2021 i don't think when he
leaves at the end of season 2 that his
story is over to me it felt like a new
chapter but it didn't feel like a
resolution so there's still more for
tyler jessup will be joined by amelia
jones and jackson robert scott who play
his younger siblings kinsey and bodhi
darby stanchfield will also be returning
as their mom nina locke along with aaron
ashmore who plays duncan the locked
children's uncle meanwhile sherry sam
who plays ellie has been promoted to
series regular which means we might also
see more of kobe byrd who plays her son
rufus kevin durand will also be getting
more screen time as the revolutionary
war soldier captain frederick gideon
the dramatic second season of lock and
key came to a conclusion at the same
time as matheson academy's fall semester
at the end of the season finale nina
reveals that tyler is going traveling
over the winter break because he needs a
fresh start however the trailer for
season 3 places tyler squarely in the
middle of all the action alongside his
family so viewers can expect some time
to have a lapse between the second and
third seasons this means that the
earliest the series could be set is the
beginning of the spring semester with
tyler returning to finish his education
however it's also possible that more
time has passed taking viewers to the
end of the summer semester in tyler's
last few weeks at matheson academy
alternatively there could be less of a
school focus this season and the show
could be set entirely during the summer
holidays giving the lock family plenty
of time to deal with the show's latest
villain
for the last two seasons lock and key
has had a revolving door of villains and
antagonists however in season three
tyler kinsey bodie nina and duncan will
be facing a new villain and that's
frederick gideon who the hell are you
your captain
this revolutionary war captain played by
kevin durand made his debut in
flashbacks seen during the first episode
of season 2. he appeared in a total of
four episodes which explain his
backstory and how a demon took over his
body when he found the black door in the
sea caves in the last episode of season
2 the demon inhabiting eden's body
brought captain gideon back as an echo
initially unaware that a demon was also
inhabiting his body after throwing eden
into the well gideon left with the
anywhere key during a round table
interview showrunner carlton hughes
explained that duran's character will be
a deadly threat to the lock family
saying meredith and i were faced with a
challenge of how do we up the stakes and
come up with a source of villainy that
will feel like an escalation and also be
compelling that led us to create the
character of gideon and kevin seemed
like the perfect guy to play him
one of the biggest changes going into
season 3 of lock and key is that tyler
has no memory of the magic he and his
siblings discovered at key house in the
final episode of season 2 tyler leaves
to go traveling my past is always with
us
[Music]
he plans to return after his 18th
birthday with no memory of magic despite
having spent most of the season
searching for the memory key which would
allow him to remember magic as an adult
instead he tells his siblings that he
wants to live a normal life after his
birthday and opts not to remember magic
after all magic caused the death of his
dad and his girlfriend becoming a major
source of emotional trauma for him i
want to have a normal life however it
seems like a magic free life might not
be in the cards for tyler especially
with captain gideon lurking in the
shadows and tyler certainly appears to
have his memories back in the trailer
lock and key has always been a very
family oriented show however the events
of the season 2 finale have seen some
significant changes that will affect the
lock family dynamic plus tyler's bonds
with his siblings will undoubtedly
change after he forgets about magic
meanwhile nina will probably grow closer
to her children now that she knows about
magic as it's been a barrier between
them in previous seasons essentially
season 3 will focus on how the lox
navigate these changes and come together
to face captain gideon as show runner
meredith aberyl teased to collider the
third season focuses much more heavily
on the family they're going to face the
greatest threat they've had to face yet
that really bonds them in a way that
we've never seen before i can't say more
than that
kinsey and scott finally getting
together is something viewers of the
show have been waiting for ever since
our budding romance was dashed after
gabe swooped in and grabbed kinsey's
attention of course gabe turned out to
be the evil demon echo dodge so that
relationship was pretty much doomed from
the start as kinsey started to uncover
gabe's true identity she and scott fell
for each other again but their timing
wasn't great season two concluded with
the couple about to embark on a
long-distance relationship as scott
chose to attend film school in london
for a year before going to college
however scott's nickname for kinsey is
rocky road and that could be what the
couple are in for in season 3. in fact
netflix has yet to confirm that patrice
jones who plays scott is returning for
the third season and he doesn't appear
in the trailer other cast members have
posted behind the scenes photos for the
new season on instagram but jones is
strangely missing from the snaps that
said it's very possible jones return to
the show is just being kept under wraps
for dramatic effect and kinsey and scott
will end up back together in season
three
i'm here
you know if you need me
while patrice jones's return is up in
the air another lock love interest is
definitely due back in matheson for
season 3. brendan hines will once again
be featured as nina's on-again off-again
partner josh bennett the pair left their
relationship up in the air last season
when josh told nina he finally felt able
to move on from his wife's death and
commit to her properly she shut him down
in the season finale nina explained that
she wasn't ready and told him that she
needed more time before they could be
together however they certainly left
things open-ended with the possibility
for their relationship to blossom in
season 3. however if nina and josh do
rekindle their romance the fact that she
knows about magic might make things a
bit more difficult for them going
forward
it's always exciting when a lock and key
character reveals a new magical key and
thankfully there's more excitement to
come in season 3. duncan now has the
ability to make keys which is a good
skill to have with a super villain on
the loose according to the comics
created by joe hill there are still
plenty of keys left for the locks to
find and the trailer introduces a pretty
major one it looks like bodhi discovers
the time shift key allowing users to see
visions of the past when used in the
lock's grandfather clock this could
certainly come in handy as the lock
family tried to discover more about
captain gideon's past in order to defeat
him it also might come into play for
tyler when he gets his memories back as
he could see visions of his past self
using magic this key this
this key can make it so you never forget
season 2 also introduced a lot of new
keys to the show in addition to the ones
established in the first season fans are
certainly eager to see more keys like
the angel key which kinsey used in the
finale and was instrumental in helping
to defeat dodge
season 3 will be the lock family's last
paranormal adventure on netflix the show
hasn't been cancelled though as it was
always the plan to end the story after
three seasons according to
co-showrunners carlton hughes and
meredith averill lock and key will
naturally reach its conclusion at the
end of season 3 with the duo telling
deadline in a statement once we began
working on the series we felt three
seasons was the ideal length to bring
the story of the lock family and their
key house adventures to a satisfying
conclusion they also sang the praises of
writer joe hill and illustrator gabriel
rodriguez who created the lock and key
comic book series and joked we're
keeping the magical keys though for our
own personal use
since cues and abarrill have been
planning the conclusion of lock and keys
since the end of season 1 they should
have the opportunity to tie up all of
the show's loose threads so here's
hoping fans get everything they want to
see and more in season 3 of lock and key
the locking key showrunners have been
keeping quiet about a lot of the
particulars in the upcoming season but
the trailer does reveal a few extra
details for fans for one it looks like
gideon is creating an army while his
motives aren't clear the trailer
suggests he's coming for the keys and
possibly even key house itself however
gideon's evil plans appear to culminate
in a big battle between his army and the
lox
this is our house those keys belong to
us viewers can definitely expect to see
an epic showdown as tyler kinsey bodie
nina and duncan defend their home in the
keys in the battle to end all battles
this fight promises to be a satisfying
and dramatic conclusion to the final
season of lock and key
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite netflix shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you